[Music]
it's 1816 a 35 year old doctor by the
name of Rene lynnie is walking through
Paris he pauses to watch as two children
signal to each other across a long piece
of wooden board one child holds the
board to her ear the other scratches the
opposite end sending the amplified sound
down the length of wood later
lanique is called to assess a young
woman with a heart condition the patient
is purportedly quite well developed and
lanique expresses some hesitation in
pressing his year directly against her
chest
remembering the children with the board
lennick in a moment of vision and
dignity tightly rolls a sheet of paper
and places one end to his ear and one
end over the young woman's heaving bosom
he is delighted by the clarity of the
sound lanique spends the next three
years developing and testing various
materials and mechanisms before settling
on a hollow wooden tube with detachable
plug his device becomes the forerunner
to the metal plastic and rubber
stethoscope we still use today
[Music]
you